R
AND A STRONG SERVER, BUT BE SAFE
THERE.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS IS
NOW HITTING BACK ON QUESTIONS ON
WHY SHE HAS TO VISIT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER ADDED DOMINIC AS
IT'S BEEN 77
DAYS, THE VICE PRESIDENT
SUGGESTING A REAL FOCUS SHOULD
NOT BE ON OUR BORDER, BUT ON
WHAT'S GOING ON AND SPACES LIKE
GUATEMALA AND MEXICO.
WATCH.
>> CAN YOU SAY YOU WILL VISIT
THE U.S. BORDER?
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
YES, I WILL AND I HAVE BEFORE.
THE REALITY OF IT IS WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE BORDER AND WE HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE WHAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO THE BORDER.
I THINK IT SHORTSIGHTED FOR ANY
OF US WHO ARE IN THE BUSINESS OF
PROBLEM-SOLVING TO SUGGEST WE
ARE ONLY GOING TO RESPOND TO THE
REACTION AS OPPOSED TO
ADDRESSING THE CAUSE.
>> Emily: THE VICE PRESIDENT
IS NOT PROVIDING DATES ON A
VISIT.
>> DEAL PLANS TO VISIT THE
BORDER?
>> NOT TODAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I HAVE BEFORE.
>> MADAME VICE PRESIDENT, THERE
ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY YOU AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAVE YET TO
VISIT THE BORDER.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU CAN ANSWER
SOME OF THOSE.
>> THE REASON I AM HERE, MY
FIRST TRIP AS VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, THIS IS ONE
OF OUR HIGHEST PRIORITIES.
I CAME HERE TO BE HERE ON THE
GROUND, TO SPEAK TO THE LEADER
OF THIS NATION AROUND WHAT WE
CAN DO, IN A WAY THAT
SIGNIFICANT AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO BE FOCUSED ON THAT KIND OF
WORK AS OPPOSED TO GRAND
GESTURE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO THE BORDER.
WE'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
THIS WHOLE THING ABOUT THE
BORDER, WE'VE BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TO THE
>> AND I HAVEN'T BEEN TO EUROPE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE POINT
YOU'RE MAKING.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> Emily: HERE WE SEE HER
GETTING MORE AND MORE DEFENSIVE
BY THE DAY, DIGGING IN ABOUT WHY
SHE DOESN'T HAVE TO GO TO THE
BORDER.
>> Tomi: YOU KNOW IT'S BAD
WHEN SOMEONE FROM A LEFTIST
MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS TO ASK THE
QUESTION BECAUSE WE KNOW
GENERALLY THEY DON'T LIKE TO DO
THAT.
COME ALL ASIDE, I WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE REPORTING,
TALKING ABOUT THE 75
GRANDFATHER, NOBODY WATCHES THAT
AND DOESN'T FEEL FOR THAT WOMAN
AND OTHERS, I WANT TO SEE A
COUPLE OF POINTS.
SHE'S COMING FROM VENEZUELA, FOR
THOSE OF US IN THIS COUNTRY,
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
LET YOUR NATION GET TAKEN OVER
BY SOCIALISTS.
YOU HAVE TO FLEE FROM IT.
I'VE SAID IT BEFORE, NOBODY
FLEES FROM THE UNITED STATES,
BUT MANY PEOPLE FLEE TO IT SO
THAT'S A REMINDER TALKING ABOUT
THIS BORDER CRISIS.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH OR CALM A LOT
TO, DO NOT COME.
WHEN YOU'RE PROMISING THEM
HEALTH CARE, ONE YOUR PROMISING
THEM THEY WILL BE CAUGHT AND
RELEASED WHEN YOU'RE GIVING
STIMULUS CHECKS, THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO COME OVER WHETHER
YOU HAVE A HALF-HEARTED
RESPONSE.
THEY ARE GOING TO COME OVER.
AS I SAY EVERY TIME I'M ON THE
SHOW AND EVERY TIME WE TALK
ABOUT ROOT CAUSES, SHE WENT ON
HER PHOTO UP.
WHEN YOU ALLOW AN OPEN BORDER
YOU ARE FUNDING THE CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
DESTROYING THESE NATIONS.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN OPEN BORDER
YOU'RE NOT ONLY DESTROYING OUR
NATION, BUT YOU'RE ALSO FUNDING
THE ORGANIZATION.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE NEED
TO SECURE OUR BORDER NOT ONLY
FOR OUR COUNTRY, BUT FOR THOSE
COUNTRIES AS WELL SO THEY CAN
GET BACK ON TRACK.
THEY'RE NOT BEING FUNDED THE WAY
THEY ARE NOW BECAUSE OF THIS
ENTERPRISE.
DO YOU WANT TO KNOW THE ROOT
CAUSES?
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO GO TO
GUATEMALA TO FIND THEM.
YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
BORDER AND HAVE COMMON SENSE.
>> Emily: LEO, YOU SAW THE
VICE PRESIDENT SAYING, MY
PHYSICAL PRESENCE DENOTES THE
PRIORITY.
THIS SENDS THE MESSAGE OF HOW
MUCH I PRIORITIZE MY WORK WITH
YOU.
AS THEY POINT OUT, THAT SENDS
THE MESSAGE THAT HER ABSENCE AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER SENDS THE
MESSAGE THAT IT'S NOT A PRIORITY
AND ESTABLISHING A MEANINGFUL
BORDER.
RIGHT NOW THE OPEN BORDER IS NOT
COMPASSIONATE, IT'S SIMPLY CRUEL
TO IGNORE THE ROOT CAUSE THAT
COMES FROM HER OWN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Leo: YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
I'M LISTENING TO HER AS A
LAWYER, WHAT DID SHE ACCOMPLISH
BY GOING TO MEXICO AND
GUATEMALA?
IT WAS A PHOTO OFF AND SHE GOT
DESTROYED BY THE REPORTERS.
SHE ACCOMPLISHED ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
WHEN SHE TALKED ABOUT THE ROOT
CAUSE, THIS COUNTRY IS NOT INTO
NATION-BUILDING GUATEMALA OR
MEXICO.
WE HAVE A SECURE BORDER ON
JANUARY 19TH, 2021.
IT HAS BEEN LET LOOSE BY THE
BIDEN -- HARRIS ADMINISTRATION.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM.
KAMALA HARRIS IS OVERHEAD.
SHE DOES WANT TO BE THERE.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO BE THERE AT
ALL!
SHE WAS FORCED TO GO THERE,
PRIMARILY FROM FOX NEWS
CONSERVATIVE OUTLETS CONSTANTLY
SHOWING THE SITUATION.
WHAT IS YOUR GAME?
I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW, YOU
HAVE NO POLITICAL FUTURE.
YOU HAVE NO POLITICAL FUTURE AND
THIS WILL HAUNT HER!
THE PROBLEM IS SIMPLY THIS, WHEN
SHE CAN BECOME SARCASTIC AND
SHOW THAT NERVOUS LAUGH WHICH IS
A DEFENSIVE POSTURE OF HER
INABILITY TO HANDLE THIS ISSUE,
IT COMES ACROSS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
IF SHE'S GIVING ORDERS FROM THE
LEFT, SHE'S IN TROUBLE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS, LET'S
BE CLEAR, THE BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS NO GAME PLAN
FOR THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
SHE WANTS AMERICA TO IGNORE IT.
YOU WILL NEVER IGNORE THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, KAMALA HARRIS.
>> Emily: THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
AND ESPECIALLY IN CONJUNCTION
WITH -- SHE'S IN CHARGE OF
VOTING RIGHTS WHEN SHE CAME
AFTER, MINUTES AFTER THE
PRESIDENT NAMED HER, SHE CAME
OUT WITH A STATEMENT.
TO YOUR POINT, IT'S SO CLEAR HOW
MUCH SHE HATES THIS JOB AND THAT
SHE IS IN FACT OVERWHELMED.
THERE WAS ONE REPORTER HOWEVER
THAT DIDN'T DESTROY HER.
I WILL SHOW YOU A VIDEO.
WHEN MARIA FERNANDA WAS
ALLEGEDLY ASKING A QUESTION, IT
ENDED UP NOT BEING HER.
IT ENDED UP BEING A FAN GIRL.
WATCH THIS MOMENT.
WE WILL GET YOUR REACTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> OUR NEXT QUESTION COMES FROM
MARIA FERNANDA AT UNIVISION.
>> THANK YOU HIM MY DOWN
VICE PRESIDENT.
IT'S AN HONOR BECAUSE I GOT TO
VOTE FOR THE FIRST TIME AS A
NATIONALIZED CITIZEN.
>> Kayleigh: THAT SUMS UP THE
TRIP.
THAT WAS NOT A REAL REPORTER.
THEY'RE LOOKING INTO IT.
THIS TRIP WENT HORRIBLY.
IT'S NOT JUST COME OUT MY FRIEND
LEO SAYING THIS IS GOING TO
HAUNT HER.
DEMOCRAT OPERATIVES HAVE PULLED
THE HILL ON BACKGROUND, THIS
TRIP IS GOING TO HAUNT HER.
THEY SAID, WHO WANTS THE BORDER
ON THE LIST OF POLITICAL DUTIES
BECAUSE THEY SAY IT'S A
HOT-BUTTON ISSUE, IT'S HARD TO
SOLVE, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE
MAKING WRONG DECISIONS.
WHEN YOU HAVE AOC, SHE'S LOST
HER FRIENDS ON THE FAR LEFT.
45% OF AMERICANS APPROVE OF THE
WAY JOE BIDEN IS HANDLING THE
BORDER.
AND NOW THE WHITE HOUSE IS EVEN
COMING OUT, WHITE HOUSE
INSIDERS.
I SAW THIS ON CNN.
THEY TOLD HER THIS, "WE ARE
STUNNED BY KAMALA HARRIS'
INABILITY TO ANSWER A QUESTION."
DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING HER OUT,
SHE'S GOT A LOT OF PROBLEMS ON
HER HANDS, GIVEN THE VOTING
RIGHTS MISSION AS WELL BY
JOE MANCHIN.
SHE'S FAILING MISERABLY AT EACH
OF THE TASKS THAT HAVE BEEN
GIVEN TO HER.
>> Emily: YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Harris: PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION WAS ABOUT HOW THEY
WERE FORCED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THIS
SPIRIT I'M LOOKING AT A REPORT
FROM COLBY HALL, A MEDIA WRITER,
THEY SAID, DID YOU SEE WHAT CNN
DID?
WHITE HOUSE PERPLEXED BY THE
PERFORMANCE ON FIRST FOREIGN
POLICY.
THIS COMING FROM JEREMY DIAMOND.
UNNAMED WHITE HOUSE INSIDERS
WERE LEFT PERPLEXED BY THE
PERFORMANCE OF VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS ON HER RECENT TRIP TO
GUATEMALA.
REMEMBER WHEN SHE STARTED.
SHE SAID, JEREMY, LET ME TELL
YOU SOMETHING.
SHE WAS KIND OF TOUGH ON HIM
BECAUSE SHE KNEW THE QUESTIONS
WERE COMING.
IT'S GOT TO BE UNCOMFORTABLE
NOW.
YOU ARE CAUGHT BETWEEN A ROCK
AND A HARD PLACE.
YOU MENTIONED AOC IS TAKING HER
TO TOWN.
PROGRESSIVES ARE NOT HAPPY.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S LISTENING
OR NOT.
THE PRESIDENT PUTS HER IN CHARGE
OF SOMETHING THAT WILL BE A
POLITICAL POWDER KEG IF SHE
WANTS TO GO FORWARD.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IF THIS IS THE LILY PAD SHE HAS
TO STAND ON TO GET TO THE
PRESIDENCY NEXT ROUND, I HOPE
SHE CAN SWIM.
WHAT YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS BEING
SAID AND DONE, SHE TALKS TO THE
LEADERS OF GUATEMALA AND MEXICO.
HER SINGLE MESSAGE COMING BACK
IS, DON'T COME.
SHE'S NOT LISTENING TO THE
PRESIDENT'S POLICIES.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT?
IT'S TIME TO ASK THAT QUESTION
AND SHE BETTER HAVE AN ANSWER
QUICKLY.
I DON'T CARRY HOW MANY COOKIES
SHE CARRIES WITH HER.
>> Emily: SHE TALKS ABOUT
GOING TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER AS
A GRAND GESTURE, BUT WE CALL
THAT SHOWING UP.
>> Harris: THE BORDER SHE WEN